[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
philosophie diesmal auf dem gottlieb
duttweiler institute in rüschlikon für
meinen heutigen gast hat die philosophie
vor allem eine aufgabe sie soll
verwehren und fragen stellen fragen
beantworten mag mein gast hingegen nicht
besonders gern unser gespräch kann also
heiter werden
ich freue mich umso mehr dass
hlawatschek hier ist 1000 verfahren
ideen und worte die einen dutzenden von
büchern zu wilden welt deutungen
zusammen schickt der vielfach
preisgekrönte professor für philosophie
und psychoanalyse begeistert
gleichermaßen wie er aneckt die einen
feiern ihn aus super fahrer linken für
die anderen ist er als enfant terrible
der philosophie er selber mag keine
fremd zuschreibungen und deshalb frage
ich ihn lieber gleich selbst slawische
check wer sind sie was weiß ich nicht
und ich will das nicht wissen sie haben
ziemlich korrekt beschrieben
aber ich glaube nicht dass es hier um
eine plauderei geht
ich glaube gerade in der aktuellen
situation ist es vielleicht viel
wichtiger die richtige frage zu stellen
heißt bloß antworten zu empfangen und
das problem mit ideologie aus dass die
fragestellungen falsch angeht
nehmen wir die ökologie wir alle wissen
das ist ein problem
wie aber sehen wir es betrachten wir es
von einem konservativen gesichtspunkt
aus dass wir zurück sollten zu alten
naturnahen gemeinschaften oder von einem
kommunistischen dass nur eine zentrale
regierung sie sehen vielleicht wichtiger
als eine antwort ist die richtige frage
da gibt es eine ganze theorie
ich will unser geneigtes publikum damit
nicht langweilen aber für mich ist der
springende punkt dass es heißt ich würde
es vorziehen nicht zu wort und ich ziehe
es nicht vor etwas zu tun
nicht die aussage wird verneint sondern
eine nicht aussage behauptet
was ist der unterschied country hat eine
wunderbare beschreibung dieses
unterschieds weshalb er für mich der
größte zombie theoretiker ist sehen sie
wenn ich ihnen sage sie sind nicht tot
verneine ich eine eigenschaft was
bedeutet es bedeutet einfach dass sie
lebendig sind wenn sie nicht tot sind
aber wenn ich sage ich hoffe sie kennen
stephen king und all das
wenn ich ihnen anstelle von sie sind
nicht tot sage sie sind und tod heißt
das etwas anderes lebendige tote monster
usw
und in diesem zwischen bereich liegt
irgendwie die sphäre des geistes in der
wunderbaren doppeldeutigkeit des
begriffs geist meint reines denken und
die geister die uns angst machen uns
terrorisieren
ich glaube diese mehrdeutigkeit ist
entscheidend um die betonung geht dann
negativität erzählen immer diesen weg
von einem kopftor in ein restaurant
kommt er bestellt einen kaffee ohne raum
unter keiner sagt leider haben wir
keinen raum mehr ich bringe ihnen einen
kaffee ohne milch weil wir nur mich
haben dich ist ein unterschied kaffee
und milch oder kaffee sehen sie in
meiner volksrepublik wo ich
innenminister wäre würden sie zwei jahre
freies erziehungs lager kassieren nicht
gut denn genau darum geht es bei hegel
es ist das beste beispiel für das was
hegel bestimmte negation nennt das die
negation teil eines objekts ist was es
nicht ist natürlich ist kaffee ohne
milch material das gleiche lied kaffee
ohne rahm einfach schwarzer kaffee aber
trotzdem ist es nicht das gleiche
weil es eben darauf ankommt was negiert
wird
ich gebe ihnen eine wunderschöne
variation dieses witzes aus meiner
jugend sie wissen ich lebte in einem
kommunistischen land war nicht allzu
schlimm ein liberaler kommunismus aber
trotzdem
man konnte nicht immer alles bekommen
aufgewachsen ist ich war ich erinnere
mich der witz ging so jemand betritt
einen laden und fragt haben sie immer
noch keine butter und die person dort
antwortet entschuldigen sie sie sind im
falschen daten
wir sind der laden der kein öl hat der
laden der keine butter hat es dort
drüben auf der anderen straßenseite die
ihnen das erziehungs lager gehen
also ich nehme bezug auf philosophie im
alltag nein entschuldigung auf ideologie
im alltag
ich glaube aber dass zu erklären würde
zu viel zeit brauchen
das ist eine art wie ideologie betrügt
sie bietet ihnen kaffee an und
impliziert dass es kaffee und milch ist
aber in wirklichkeit ist das café dieser
hintergrund dir fehlt und gleichzeitig
da ist ist entscheidend ich gebe ihnen
ein weiteres beispiel mit dem ich in
meinem buch zeige wie dieser unerwähnt
hintergrund funktioniert in einem
hübschen alten englischen linken film
brassed off gibt es eine der
erotischsten szenen die je gesehen hat
mcgregor spielt einen gewöhnlichen
arbeiter der in eine junge garde
mitarbeiterin verliebt ist er begleitet
sie nach hause und sie lädt ihn zu sich
nach oben
sie sagt dem möchtest du auf einen
kaffee in meiner wohnung kommen
er sagt ich kenne sehr gerne aber leider
trinke ich keinen kaffee
wissen sie was sie antwortet kein
problem ich habe keinen können sie sich
eine direktere erotische einladung
vorstellen aber mit keinem wort wird
etwas schmutziges gesagt solche
phänomene zeigen wie ideologie im alltag
funktioniert ich mag sie für mich sind
sie das grund phänomen
der nullpunkt die ideologie mich
fasziniert dass immer wieder so genannte
gesten die zum ziel haben zurückgewiesen
zu werden
wie nehmen wir an wir sind in einem
restaurant
sie sind reich ich bin sie laden mich
ein
wahrscheinlich ist es hierzulande gleich
wie in meinem land sogar wenn wir beide
wissen dass sie zahlen werden wenn die
rechnung kommt werden wir ja ja ich muss
ein wenig insistieren nicht zu sehr wenn
ich zu sehr investiere und sie böse sind
könnten sie sagen okay dann bezahlen sie
wenn sie wollen
das resultat ist gleich null absoluter
unsinn
ich machte etwas von dem ich wusste dass
es zurückgewiesen wird
aber das ist die magie der alltags
ideologie ob schon das resultat gleich
null war haben wir doch eine beziehung
hergestellt eine freundliche beziehung
das signal war wir sind höflich
zueinander vielleicht mögen wir einander
hier ist ideologie lebendig ideologie
und ideologiekritik eigentlich ihr leben
in diesem zusammenhang verweisen sie
selber sehr oft auf ein film von john
carter heißt wir leben und in diesem
film gibt es eine figur aktion nada die
hauptfigur arbeitslos er findet eine
kiste mit genau und dieser mensch der
die sonnenbrille findet schon norder
wehr setzt diese sonnenbrille auf und in
dem moment sieht er überall die
ideologien hinter den produkten hinter
den werbeplakaten auch hinter den
personen und wir schauen uns zusammen
all ausschnitt aus dem film sicher kraft
zeigt der film im film zeigt wie
ideologie in unserem alltag funktioniert
was will ich damit sagen
an diese szene mag ich zwei dinge
erstens ist es das gegenteil von dem was
man erwarten würde
normalerweise stellen wir uns ideologie
als brille vor die unserer sicht
verzerrt und um die wirklichkeit zu
sehen müsste man die brille weg
ich mag diesen sanften raffinierten dreh
dass hier das gegenteil der fall ist und
der film richtig zeigt ideologie ist
unser naturzustand und um die wahrheit
zu sehen muss man die brille aufsetzt
der st zweitens ist wichtig dass
ideologie traditionellerweise umgekehrt
funktioniert hat die offizielle
botschaft war die rein ethische ich
gehorche opfere die ich auf und dann
musste man sich eine brille aufsetzen um
die obszöne botschaft dahinter zu
erkennen
die beispiele die ich immer ne ne im
faschismus bei den nazis ist die
offizielle botschaft schluss mit der
dekadenz opfere die ich auch arbeite für
das land aber dann damit sich diese
botschaft auch umsetzen dies kann die
bestechung durch ideologie du kannst
schlagen stehlen
die juden schlagen oder was auch immer
die schmutzigen freundin wurde in
amerika der ku klux klan offiziell
christentum wir verteidigen die weiße
rasse die wahrheit dahinter wird erst
sichtbar wenn man die brille aufsetzt
samstagabend wir treffen uns
vergewaltigen ein paar schwarze mädchen
münchen ein paar schwarze in der
traditionellen ideologie sind dieser
zusätzliche - die freude an schmutzigen
fantasieren und die art wie die macht
habe sie zum mitmachen bestechen
versteckt ich heute haben wir praktisch
das gegenteil ideologie lockt direkt mit
vergnügen genießen
also brauchen wir eine brille um das
wahre bild zu sehen ich habe eine brille
mitgebrachten wir gehen jetzt mal davon
aus dass die richtige brille ich endlich
will einen bereits 1 million franken für
welche jetzt sehe ich eine schöne frau
und jetzt stehe ich
du musst nicht denken du musst nur an
sex denken du musst dumm bleiben nicht
denken frei denken okay geben sie ihr
seid wunderbar das ist meine wahre natur
lesen sie hier
landshut ist wann
darauf habe ich ihnen eine perfekte
antwort was ich hier jetzt sehe ohne
brille
ist ein wunderbares gerät
sofortnachrichten ich brauche meinen
computer nicht um e mails zu checken ich
bin mit allen in kontakt was sehe ich
jetzt bleibt verbunden weil big brother
so wer auch immer ob apple microsoft wir
haben die vollständig unter kontrolle
wir wissen wen du angerufen hast wir
informieren den ns darüber was ich hier
sehe ich kann schokolade genießen und
tut gleichzeitig etwas für mutter natur
ich leiste einen beitrag an die
ökologische stabilität und so weiter
fairtrade wie ich helfe ihnen wenn ich
die brille aufsätze sehe ich die
ideologie dahinter die lautet ich bin
konsumorientiert anstatt etwas zu tun
das wirklich veränderung bringt ich weiß
nicht etwa um den ökologischen ruine
erde aufzuhalten was auch immer statt
etwas zu tun kaufe ich das zahle ein
wenig mehr und kann mit gutem gewissen
weiterhin den konsum frönen
sorry ich habe das hier gekauft also
lassen sie mich in ruhe mit großen
politischen themen ich habe meine
pflicht gegenüber der gesellschaft
bereits erfüllt es ist pure ideologie
behaupte ich weiß dass manche vielleicht
wirklich besser sind aber ich habe immer
diesen zweifel ob es in wirklichkeit
nicht eine ideologische handeln ist wir
alle wissen dass man unser ökologisches
dilemma die mögliche katastrophe auf
dieser persönlichen ebene nicht wirklich
bekämpfen kann
du hast mehr recycelt hast du die alten
cola wuchsen gesammelt
es braucht viel radikalere das
herrschende system die kennen wir eine
einfache möglichkeit sie müssen nur ein
wenig recyceln dies kaufen damit haben
sie ihre pflicht getan und können weiter
dem konsum frühling man ermöglicht ihnen
etwas zu tun aber die funktion dieses
etwas da sind wir wieder bei hegel
gestimmte negation bedeutet entscheidend
ist was sieht nichts tun müssen wenn sie
das hier kaufen
aber eigentlich sind ja schon dafür dass
man beispielsweise die
produktionsbedingungen sagen wir mal auf
kakaoplantagen verbessert wenn sie die
wahl haben zwischen der schokolade bei
denen der kakao verbaut wurde gegenüber
den bei dem das nicht der fall ist dann
müssen sie doch nicht mit
lassen sie mich klarstellen natürlich
weiß ich bin kein chemiker ich glaube
einfach nicht recht vielleicht so riesig
so melancholisch dass es wirklich
funktioniert zum beispiel russland das
ist vielleicht ein extremfall aber meine
russischen freunde erzählen mir dass
dort bei großen aktionen um krebskranken
kindern zu helfen oder so wenn sie glück
haben kommen zehn prozent des
gesammelten geldes wirklich diesen
kindern zugute
das gleiche würde ich sagen
natürlich unterstütze ich allgemein
bioprodukte und so aber offen gesagt
glaube ich nicht dass es funktioniert
die erste grund weshalb ich nicht glaube
dass es funktioniert ist ich bin ein
grüner aber ein viel radikaler ich bin
kein nostalgischer grüner
damit will ich sagen ich bin nicht gegen
die umweltverschmutzung weil wir die
menschheit mit unserer hybris das
gleichgewicht von mutter erde zerstören
und deshalb bescheidener leben sollten
usw
ich glaube die situation ist viel
verrückter und schwierig
mag sein dass die erde unsere mutter ist
aber sie ist eine böse hexe eine
schreckliche mutter denken sie nur ans
erdöl
können sie sich vorstellen welch
schreckliche ökologische katastrophen
dazu führten dass wir heute erdöl haben
damit will ich sagen die tragödie ist
dass es kein ökologisches gleichgewicht
gibt keine nullpunkt zu den hier
zurückkehren können
nein wir leben in einem offenen
verrückten zufälligen universum von
einem deutschen ökologen habe ich
gelesen leider habe ich seinen namen
vergessen
er hat einen wunderbaren ernst zu nehmen
den text geschrieben in dem er zeigt
dass sich unsere erde bereits so sehr an
unsere umweltverschmutzung angepasst hat
dass sie aus dem gleichgewicht geworfen
würde wenn man damit allzu schnell
aufhören würde
und wer weiß was für katastrophen das
wiederum zur folge hätte deshalb noch
einmal ich nehme die ökologie sehr ernst
aber genau deshalb mag ich diese
einfachen ausweg nicht dass ich
eigentlich eben überhaupt nicht bin und
jetzt möchte ich noch mal darauf den
punkt daher zurückkommen ich die brille
abnehmen sie haben ja darauf hingewiesen
die pro a team film ist auch das um die
ideologie zu sehen muss man die brille
anzieht wird sozusagen ideologie ist
eigentlich unsere natur
nein das gehört zum wesen der ideologie
dass sie es nicht merken wenn sie es
einmal gemerkt haben sind sie nicht mehr
in der ideologie drin in dem journal
die brille seinem freund geben wenn aber
der freund will sie nicht das ist eine
weitere tiefgründige lektion
ja genau das im film matrix haben sie
eine ähnliche szene in der ein tier sich
von dem atrix in der maschine
korrigieren lassen will sagt mich
interessiert die wahrheit nicht ich bin
bloß glücklich sein in meiner illusion
ich bin da viel pessimistischer
ich glaube sogar dordrecht schrieb
einmal dass die wahrheit schmerzt sie
ist schmerzhaft der frei und ist
schmerzhaft befreiung heißt nicht oh
mein gott jetzt bin ich glücklich und so
weiter ein anderer film vielleicht
kennen ihn einige zuschauer erinnern sie
sich mit brad pitt und norden fightclub
da gibt es eine wunderbare szene in der
ed norden seinen chef schlagen will aber
seine faust verwandelt sich sozusagen in
ein autonomes objekt und schlägt ihn
selber
das ist der anfang von ideologiekritik
um den pfeil zu bewältigen müssen sie
entschuldigen sie den ausdruck die
scheiße zuerst aus sich selber
herausprügeln bezug auf vielmehr das ist
ja auch in ihren büchern sohn es gibt
auch ganz vielen datenbanken die sie
aufbauen gehen sie viel mehr besprechen
vielmehr erklären wenn ihr mal davon
ausgehen dass sie auch sagen hollywood
ist eigentlich pure ideologie in
hollywood findet ihr alle die ideologien
erklärt und auch eben transparenter
macht man könnte auch sagen na ja ein
großteil von hollywood ist ja eigentlich
sind romantische komödien liebe liebe
mag eine illusion sein aber ich liebe
eine ideologie nein
als erstes möchte ich klarstellen ich
verdamme hollywood nicht hollywood es
ist eine wunderbare vieldeutige
ideologische maschinerie mit einer
vorherrschende ideologie aber immer
wieder gibt es regisseure die diese
ideologie von ihnen hier in terminieren
ich gebe ihnen ein schönes beispiel
robert altman shortcuts das ist die
gründlichste beste ideologiekritik die
ich kenne
an die trostlosigkeit des alltäglichen
amerikanischen mittelklasse leben
ich gehöre nicht zu dieser sorte
fetischisten die glauben für wahrhafte
gefühle taugten nur langweilige
kunstwerke oder drittweltländer oder was
weiß ich nein
schon bei den hollywood klasse kamen ich
glaube immer noch an alfred hitchcock
ganz zu schweigen von das chemie
allerdings ist ernst lubitsch ich finde
man sollte hollywood wirklich genau
anschauen und verstehen wie sich
hollywood in seinen besten produkten
selber unterminiert liebe das beste
thema wein ist die ideologie war nichts
da bin ich das mag sie erstaunen erst
einmal um vier romantisch ich glaube
nicht dass liebe bloß eine ideologische
sentimentale maske ist und es in
wirklichkeit um gewalt sex und was auch
immer geht was ist liebe ich glaube
nicht an die universelle liebe bei der
man liebe und politik vermischt für mich
ist das ultimative statement über die
universelle liebe erinnern sie sich an
die letzten worte von erich mielke in
der volkskammer der ddr als das system
schon am auseinanderfallen war und
mitglieder der volkskammer ihn angriffen
worauf ihr diese legendäre geste machte
es ist universelle liebe für mich ist
authentische leidenschaftliche liebe
eine katastrophe was hass liebe ich lebe
allein habe ein glückliches leben treffe
mich mit freunden trinken bier habe
vielleicht mal hier mal dort einen one
night stand
und dann geschieht etwas absolut blödes
ich gehe die straße entlang rutsche auf
einer bananenschale aus eine frau hilft
mir wieder aufzustehen ich schaue sie an
sie ist die liebe meines lebens und
eigentlich esse keine banane
das ist ein modell stellen sie sich die
katastrophe vor ich kann mein leben
nicht länger in ruhe genießen
ich bin völlig besessen von ihr alles
gerät aus den fugen um es mit
shakespeare zu sagen
das aber ist für mich das absolute da
bin ich metaphysiker das ist die
elementare metaphysische erfahren
physischer erfahrungen wir uns zum
alltag
ich kümmere mich um eine vergnügungen ja
aber glaube ich sind wir menschen
metaphysische wesen wenn sie sich auf
etwas fixieren dass diese dummen
täglichen rhythmen einfach unterbricht
und sie bereit sind alles dafür zu
opfern
in dieser beziehung hatte freud recht
als er das mensch werden in der
sexualität lokalisiert wenn freud über
sexualität spricht geht es nicht um
animalische sexualität
es ist genau diese sexuelle leidenschaft
die über das lustprinzip hinausgeht die
dich total auslöst und sich zum sklaven
eine art metaphysischer besessenheit
macht
ich glaube das ist wahre liebe
wahre liebe ist eine katastrophe deshalb
ist es schön verliebt zu sein
ich glaube sogar um es plakativ zu sagen
dass sex ohne liebe vergnüglich sein
kann aber es hat die struktur von
selbstbefriedigung beim sex ohne liebe
brauchen wir uns gegenseitig im
wesentlichen los als selbstbefriedigung
einheiten
lassen sie mich eine anekdote erzählen
die alle zu diesem punkt erarbeitet
haben der vor drei jahren hat mich der
guardian gefragt wie die ideale romanze
heute aussehen wird und ob es das
überhaupt noch geben
ich sagte folgendes würde geschehen
nehmen wir an wir flirten miteinander
und schließlich beschließen wir es zu
tun
aber wie ich bringe diese vulgäre
maschine mit der plastik vagina mit die
man ans stromnetz anschließt und wenn
man dem penis hineinsteckt schüttelte
connect electric und sie bringen ihren
plastik penis mit
und keine angst es endet nicht woher das
ist das schöne
wir setzen uns hin und sagen lasst es
uns tun
okay wir tun es sie stecken ihr gerät
einig das meinige sie stecken ihren
plastik fairness im eine plastik wagen
ein und wir sehen wenn die maschinen
aber sie genießen für uns wären wir
einen schönen tee trinken und über
philosophie oder was auch immer sprechen
können um aber aus diesem selbst
befriedigen den künstlichen genießen
auszubrechen braucht es die liebe
ideologie zuliebe gekommen kommen wir
noch einmal zurück zur ideologie wir
leben heute ja nicht mehr in einer
disziplinar gesellschaft wie das früher
der fall war in der die ideologiekritik
groß geworden ist sondern wir leben in
einer liberalen gesellschaft wir haben
sehr viele freiheiten
dennoch sehen sie uns ein stück weit aus
verschlechterte individuen
wer sitzt denn jetzt an der schauen den
schalthebeln der macht das muss nicht
sein dass dort tatsächlich jemand sitzt
was mich aber fasziniert ist wie
ausgerechnet heute in einer offiziellen
post ideologischen ihrer ideologie näher
denn je unseren alltag strukturiert der
große erfolg der heutigen ideologie ist
dass uns die neuen formen der
versklavung und unterordnung als neue
formen von freiheit verkauft werden sie
mich ein beispiel geben
heute haben immer weniger menschen eine
unbefristete anstellung arbeiter leben
im prekariat
in vielen ländern gibt es keine
nachhaltige gesundheitsversorgung und so
weiter die ideologie sagt ihnen ist das
nicht wunderbar sie nicht länger auf
eine einzige rolle festgelegt jedes jahr
können sie sich neu erfinden
zur tatsache dass sie keine ständige
gesundheitsversorgung haben sagen sie
ihnen jeder von uns ist ein kleiner
kapital ist sagen wir sie haben 5000
euro sie können frei entscheiden wie sie
dieses geld investieren wollen ob für
die gesundheitsvorsorge für einen
hübschen urlaub für eine spezielle
ausbildung sie sehen den trick dahinter
was in wirklichkeit eine neue form von
besorgnis
und stress ist wird ihnen als neue form
von freiheit verkauft ich will ihnen ein
anderes beispiel dafür geben wie diese
per massivität im kern sogar noch unter
drückender ist betrachten wir einmal
väterliche autorität
stellen sie sich vor sonntagnachmittag
sie sind ein kleines mädchen ihr vater
kommt zu ihnen und sagt für mal deine
großmutter hat geburtstag du musst sie
besuchen
nehmen wir an ihr vater ist ein
traditionell autoritärer vater
er wird etwas gutes tun er wird ihnen
sagen mir ist egal wie du dich fühlst du
gehst dorthin und benimmst dich
anständig das ist gut
sie können dagegen halten weil sie
wissen was sache ist
jetzt kommt aber der horror der
postmoderne alles erlauben vater
verfolgen das sagen mach was du willst
ich will dich nicht zwingend du bist
frei zu wählen aber denkt daran wie sie
dich deine großmutter liebt dich was
aber sagt ihr einen wirklich unter dem
menschlichen der freien wahl gibt er
ihnen einen viel radikaleren befehl
die botschaft ist nicht los du musst
gehen sondern du musst freiwillig gehen
für mich ist das enorm wichtig der
moderne chef ist nicht mehr der
autoritäre chef mit krawatte der moderne
chef haus mit ihnen obszöne witze aus
sie wollen nicht mal mehr chef genannt
werden sondern koordinator oder irgend
sowas hinter dieser per massiven
erscheinung steckt aber eine viel
stärkere autorität
was mich immer wieder aufs neue
fasziniert das ist weshalb meine nicht
feministische sondern post gender oder
so freundin judith butler
ich habe große auseinandersetzung mit
ihr aber einmal sagte sie etwas
wunderbares sagte weil heutzutage die
unterdrückung der frauen genau auf
dieser ebene geschieht haben wir
zumindest meistens keine direkte
männliche dominanz der faktor aber
werden sie von männern dominiert die
vorgeben sie seien alle für
gleichberechtigung und demokratisch die
erste feministische geste wäre vom mann
zu verlangen dass er sich wie ein
meister verhält
auf mit dem quatsch bitte tu nicht so
als ob wir gleichberechtigt wären wenn
wir es nicht sind und wissen sie was
heißt es funktioniert weil wir in einem
formellen liberalen zeitalter leben
da geht das nicht mehr wir leben in
einer sehr interessanten zeit in der
herrschaft die form von freiheit
annehmen muss herrschaft kann nicht mehr
offen durchgesetzt werden richtige
freiheit richtig verstanden überhaupt
möglich das mag jetzt konservativ
klingen aber ich glaube echte freiheit
hat nichts zu tun mit dieser
oberflächlichen wahlfreiheit wir gehen
in eine konditorei und es hat er per
torte oder vanille
paradoxerweise ist eine echte freie wahl
nur eine wahl die sie als erzwungene
wahl erleben sagen wir zum beispiel
irland ist von einer fremden macht
besitzt und sie müssen entscheiden ob
sie sich die widerstandsbewegung
anschließen oder nicht wenn sie
beitreten ist das nicht einfach eine
wahl
sie tun es weil ihnen eine stimme das
gewissen sagt dass sie nicht anders
können
sie müssen es tun echte freiheit ist
etwas sehr qualvolles sie schmerzt
schnitt machen hin zur politik haben
eine neue idee diesen moment vertreten
ist dass sie sagen toleranz ist auch
ideologie und ein stück weit sehe ich
natürlich toleranz ist weniger aus
akzeptanz das ist nicht die anerkennung
aber tolerant sich ja immerhin so etwas
wie die anerkennung zumindest dass es
unterschiedliche positionen geben kann
warum sollte das ideologisch verbrämt
diese idee kam mir als ich reden von
martin luther king las und feststellte
dass ihr nie intoleranz erwähnt für mich
ist toleranz ein zeichen für das was ich
kultury sierung nennt die kultury
sierung von kritischer energie was
heutzutage systematisch vorkommen
wenn wir zum beispiel von rassismus
sprechen über setzen wir das als
probleme mit toleranz schikanen und so
weiter
nein toleranz heißt einfach dass man
unterschiede akzeptiert das ist in
ordnung aber trotzdem glaube ich dass es
viel radikalere missverständnisse und
konflikte gibt wo es keinen platz für
toleranz geben sollte was meine ich
damit lassen sie mich ein beispiel geben
werden sie mich nach dem dümmsten
sprichwort oder sogenannt weisen spruch
fragen würde ich bekannte
multikulturalisten nennen die sagen ein
feind ist jemand dessen geschichte wir
nicht anhören wollten so zu sagen ich
will dich nicht verstehen deshalb mache
ich dich zum fetisch zu monster meine
antwort darauf lautet 8 endlich hekla
war also unser feind weil die nicht
bereit waren seine geschichte zu hören
nein es gibt echte feinde mein gott
zweitens ich glaube nicht das ist das
problem mit toleranz dass die richtige
haltung bei rassistischen spannungen und
ähnlichem ist wir sollten uns einfach
gegenseitig verstehen und so weiter
wissen sie deshalb das nicht
funktioniert erstens ist das eine
unmögliche aufgabe wie soll ich sie
verstehen wenn ich wahrscheinlich nicht
einmal mich selber verstehen
in diesem punkt bleibe ich ein radikaler
linker ein kommunist da bin ich
zumindest teilweise einverstanden mit
jemanden der kein idiot ist peter
sloterdijk
er sagt wir bräuchten vielmehr eine neue
kultur der diskretion
das heißt für mich bedeutet eine ideale
multikulturelle gesellschaft nicht dass
ich mit meinen freunden zusammensitzen
und wir versuchen uns gegenseitig zu
verstehen
ich möchte in einem großen gebäude leben
gegenüber von mir wohnt ein chinese dann
ein jude ein muslim ein lateinamerikaner
ein schwarzer
und wir haben höflich und mit respekt
nebeneinander
mag sein dass man sich ab und zu
wirklich versteht aber ich mag diesen
druck nicht druck dass wir gegenseitig
bei uns einbringen und auf teufel komm
raus verstehen müssen sozusagen auch die
kritik an diesem multikulturalisten
optimismus im moment der sehr fertig
sehen nämlich ein konkretes beispiel in
der schweiz gibt es gerade einen
diskussion darüber wie man damit
umzugehen hat das zwischen wieder sich
geweigert haben ihrer lehrerin die hand
zu reichen
ich weiß dass kommt heute überall vor
das ist ein sehr gutes beispiel weil ich
oft missverstanden und angeklagt werde
ich sei islamophob und so weiter nein
mein problem ist folgendes ich glaube
für die flüchtlinge endete in einer
katastrophe wenn die aufgrund dieser
paranoiden logik wenn wir offen über
dieses problem reden nutzen wir den
migrations gegnern und rassisten also
dem feind wir müssen offen darüber
sprechen
die leute unterschätzen
und da sind wir wieder bei unserem
anfangspunkt die ideologie ideologien
auf die es ankommt sind nicht die großen
formeln sozialismus und was weiß ich es
ist jener ideologie die teil unseres
alltags ist für mich ist ideologie wie
männer frauen und frauen männer brannten
im alltag sogar wie ich in einem einer
berühmten beispiele die ich immer wieder
bringen da liege wie sind toiletten
gebaut deutsche toiletten wo sie ihre
kirchen zumindest in den alten
überprüfen sich geht ab französische
toiletten die kacke verschwindet sofort
unser gesamtes alltagsleben ist davon
durchdrungen und da ist es wirklich
schwierig die ideologie zu verändern
ideologie ist mitten im zentrum unseres
täglichen lebens und hier noch einmal
hier entstehen die probleme seien wie
ehrlich wir haben probleme auf diese
heben wir haben andere probleme ich habe
zum beispiel kein problem damit wenn ein
muslimisches mädchen einen schleier
tragen will
ich bin zutiefst gegen dieses
französische gesetz dass dieses
verbietet für mich wird das aber ein
ernsthaftes problem wenn die familie das
mädchen dazu zwingt sich zu verschleiern
wenn es das nicht will den schützen wir
konkret dieses beispiel was würden sie
den raten würden sie gibt jungen zwingen
die hand zu geben oder werden sie sagen
nein
in diesem speziellen fall müsste ich
genau anschauen
aber mein wichtigstes anliegen ist lasst
uns offen darüber sprechen und klare
regeln festlegen
das ist der einzige weg ein beispiel was
tun wir helfen wir den mädchen
beschützen wir es die familie denn über
eines müssen wir uns im klaren sein wenn
wir das mädchen schützen sagt die
muslimische familie völlig zu recht ihr
toleriert unsere art zu leben nicht ihr
zerstört unseren lebensstil
denn die art wie familienbeziehungen
funktionieren ist der zentrale
bestandteil einer gewissen lebensraum
mein standpunkt ist deshalb dass wir die
regeln explizit festlegen müssen
es tut mir leid aber da bin ich ein
wenig eurozentrische im sinn von du
kannst das und das und das tun
und an diesem punkt ist schluss das
gleiche gilt natürlich auch für unsere
fundamentalisten
sie sagen ja auch ein stück weit im
moment wir brauchen wieder so etwas wie
eine europäische leitkultur sie sagen
auch sie sind für einen starken euro
ich weiß wie manche leute ist das reine
provokation aber da bin ich sehr präzis
sind sich jene die dem eurozentrismus
kritisieren bewusst dass der gesamte
konzeptuelle ansatz auf den sie sich
stützen ein europäischer ist zum
beispiel gleichberechtigung
gleichstellung der geschlechter usw
philosophisch ist das undenkbar ohne
dass kt sie amische subjekt das ist das
erste gänzlich abstrakte subjekt
deshalb waren schon zu dick arzt zeiten
viele seiner anhänger frauen sie sagten
cogito hat kein geschlecht wir
identifizieren uns ich sage das
großartige an europa die europäer haben
viel schreckliches getan von der
kolonisation über den hula bis zum
holocaust aber gleichzeitig sehe ich als
einzigen konzeptuellen ansatz um europa
zu überwinden wiederum das
aufklärerische europäische erbe ich
behaupte dieses egalitäre europäische
erbe ist absolut einmalig man findet es
bereits im christentum
ich bin atheist aber wissen sie was
heiliger geist bedeutet es meint die
möglichkeit einer gleichberechtigten
gemeinschaft ohne hierarchien
deshalb sagt jesus wie er seinen vater
seine mutter nicht hast damit meint er
als teil der gesellschaft sollte man all
diese verbindungen aufheben für mich ist
das ein mal warum ist das heute so
wichtig weil es in dem gegenwärtigen
politischen auseinandersetzungen gerade
en vogue ist den eurozentrismus zu
kritisieren
besonders in ländern die nicht besonders
demokratisch sind heute ist der globale
kapitalismus nicht mehr durch die
europäische ideologie dominiert welches
sind heute die dynamischsten
kapitalistischen länder china singapur
und so weiter
die sogenannten asiatischen werte
übrigens eine falsche bezeichnung was in
wirklichkeit nichts anderes ist als
autoritärer kapitalismus nebenfiguren
wie erdogan putin überall entwickelt
sich ein neuer autoritärer kapitalismus
und diese unterstützen die kritik am
eurozentrismus voll und ganz
das bedeutet wir können uns von diesem
gleichmacherischen erbe befreien
sagen sie auch der kapitalismus
sozusagen ohne das aufklärerische erbe
also ohne die idee sich einlassen
schwinning du und das ist sozusagen der
der kapitalismus der wirklich das
problem darstellt kapitalismus mit
eurozentrismus sitze sie nicht so
problem
nein nein in dieser beziehung bin ich
pessimistisch ich behaupte der globale
kapitalismus entwickelt sich zu etwas
neutraler wo es keine rolle spielt doch
die ideologie die ihn stützt
eurozentrische konfuzianische oder sonst
was ist
aber schritt für schritt funktioniert
immer besser ohne europäische
demokratische werte deshalb glaube ich
paradoxerweise dass es bis heute eine
natürliche verbindung zwischen
demokratie und kapitalismus mann hatte
während zehn zwanzig jahren eine
diktatur wie in chile oder korea
aber dann wenn die dinge in bewegung
geraten kommt die nachfrage nach
demokratie aber diese ewige ehe löst
sich gegenwärtig auch wir werden mehr
und mehr spannungen haben heute ist der
kapitalismus immer weniger in der lage
sich demokratie zu leisten
ich spreche nicht von einer
marxistischen authentischen demokratie
die einfache bürger die hier demokratie
die wir zurzeit haben verliert ihre
funktionsfähigkeit sogar dort wo wir sie
haben schwindet ihre bedeutung schauen
sie sich diese verträge antipathie tipp
und so weiter diese verträge von größter
tragweite die unseren wirtschaftlichen
alltag bis ins detail bestimmen werden
praktisch im geheimen aus der hand ohne
wikileaks wüssten wir nicht einmal dass
es sie gibt
so beschreiben es ja ungefähr auch das
was die leute gemeint haben wenn sie
dauernd betont haben sie möchten die
werte der offenen gesellschaft
verteidigen eurozentrismus klingt also
kultur imperialistisch und dass man sie
ja nicht aber bleiben die man diesen
punkt wenn sie diese natürlich löst der
begriff europäisches erbe spannungen aus
trotzdem lege ich wert darauf dass
unsere begriffe von emanzipation mein
gott ich bin kommunist wenn es je eine
eurozentrische in die gegebenheit dann
ist es der kommunismus bleiben möchte
ich trotzdem noch einmal mit ihnen
darüber sprechen wie rechtfertigen sie
denn darf also normalerweise würde man
ja sagen man ist dann sehr schnell auch
bei einer ideologie oder zumindest
müssen sie zugestehen dass sie an so
etwas glauben die universelle werte sie
können
was ist dann dort sozusagen die letzt
begründung im post ideologischen zeit
haben ja eigentlich uns daran gewöhnt
wir verzichten auf jetzt die gründe aber
schlug dort nein das tue ich nicht ich
bin ein europäischer metaphysik
das ist ein universelles thema wenn wir
freiheit erlangen wollen müssen wir von
den nullpunkt aus
das ist nicht eurozentrischen
rassistischen sind wissen sie wer mein
held ist ich habe darüber geschrieben
in den usa habe ich mit vielen schwarzen
freunden über ihn diskutiert marke mexx
wissen sie was das zeichen iks bedeutet
dies bedeutet wir haben keinen
familiennamen wir haben keine wurzeln
seine genialität bestand darin zu
erkennen dass das nicht nur ein nachteil
ist und schwarze menschen nun zurück
nach afrika sollten um ihre wurzeln zu
entdecken
die generalität von marke mexx war die
erkenntnis dass diese six diese wäre
gleichzeitig einen neuen freiraum
eröffnet dass wir an diesem null punkt
beginnen müssen wir sind der europäische
begriff für diese sixx ist das ktc
amische subjekt alle radikalen
emanzipatorischen bewegungen auf der
ganzen welt funktionieren so ich bin ein
großer bewunderer von tucson ouvertüre
und der haitianischen revolution
es war eine art kenianischer
wiederholung das heißt die wiederholung
war authentischer als das original die
französische revolution ein gewaltiges
ereignis schwarze sklaven die in haiti
rebellierten
sie wollten euch zu ihren authentischen
wurzeln zurück sie wollten revolutionär
französischer sein als die franzosen
selber in diesem sinn ist eurozentrismus
die einzig mögliche form von echtem
nicht eurozentrischen universalismus sie
müssen durch diesen katalanischen
nullpunkt hindurch ich gebe zu ich bin
jetzt ein bisschen verwirrt machen sie
noch einmal vielleicht das deutlich was
meinen sie mit diesen karten jannis muss
und man kommt ins spiel
es sind ganz viele verschiedene
dimensionen die sie aufrufen
menschenrechte beispielsweise wie würden
sie einer person die menschenrechte
erklären und rechtfertigen was ist
direkt ich bin mir sehr bewusst ich habe
darüber geschrieben
das konzept der menschenrechte ist
untergründig eurozentrische sie mögen
neutral erscheinen aber in der tat
bevorzugen sie weiß aber ich gebe ihnen
folgendes beispiel haben sie bemerkt am
anfang war es so ich habe gerade weil
die begriff abstrakt ist universelle
menschenrechte hatte er von anfang an
sprengkraft ende des achtzehnten
jahrhunderts mary wollstonecraft warum
nicht auch wir frauen dann die schwarzen
in haiti warum nicht auch wir schwarzen
und so weiter das ist das großartige an
europa sie haben diese menschenrechte
als ideologie und sofort explodiert das
ganze und erhält eine noch radikalere
universalität was bedeutet karte
spanisches subjekt ich sprach einmal mit
judith butler darüber und wir waren uns
einig ihr begriff von subjektivität für
sie ist das keine abstrakte theorie
es geht um den täglichen kampf der
frauen die sich nun ausweitet in alle
diese auseinandersetzungen um
transgender riss muss usw
was ist die idee die idee ist dass
unsere biologische identität was als
biologische oder sexuelle identität
erscheint nicht einfach auf simple
biologie beruht sexuelle ausprägungen
sind gesellschaftliche konstrukte und so
weiter ich behaupte ohne dass kt sie
amische subjekt wäre das undenkbar
das bedeutet sie oder ich sind nicht von
natur aus mann oder frau wir sind diese
abstrakte nullpunkt der sich kulturell
in diese oder jene richtung entwickeln
kann
für mich ist der transgender es muss
heute die bedeutendste praktische
verkörperung des katalanischen cogito
wissen sie deshalb war für jacques lacan
dem ein lehrer war er wird meist total
missverstanden wenn er sagt hysterische
frauen würden
eine maske tragen ja aber das macht sie
für lacko authentischer sogar schelling
sagt frauen tragen masken dadurch sind
sie näher an der wahrheit die
subjektivität was bei hilde die auf sich
selbst beziehen de negativität war
was bedeutet hinter der maske gibt es
nichts frauen sind die reinen lehre wir
männer sind blöd wir glauben wir hätten
ein wahres selbst ihr frauen seit weise
ihr wisst dass wir kein wahres selbst
haben
es ist nicht die otto reiniger gesagt
hat die frau ist ein misslungener mann
obwohl wir manchmal träumen dass es so
sehr wir männer sind missratene frauen
sind jetzt 67 jahre und wie wollen sie
das sich so mit ihnen spreche jetzt
werde ich chronisch das ist das problem
mit dem feminismus frauen bekommen ihre
rechte und sprechen dann so mit mir wie
alt ich bin
sorry so viel energie gibt es wie sie so
etwas auch wie das ideal der
gelassenheit wenn sie mir diese frage
stellten diese blöde frage welches
musikstück ich auf die einsame insel
mitnehmen würde dieses wunderbare
kunstwerk sehr interessant aber ich weiß
nicht weshalb ich bin hier vollkommen
verfallen
wissen sie was meine tragödie ist ich
bin ein alter sechzigerjahre reaktionär
ich bin der meinung dass alles was die
rockmusik ausmacht zwischen 1965 und 75
stattgefunden hat die rest sind bloß
kopieren
seit 40 jahren komme ich deshalb auch
die klassische musik zurück ich mag
diesen streit mit meinen freunden mein
bester freund laden dollar behauptet
schuberth ich sage nein
aber wissen sie warum wagner mich
fasziniert natürlich so weit wir das
beurteilen können als mensch war er ein
totales schweiz ohne zweifel er war
antisemitisch aber hören sie einmal was
er in seinem werk macht antisemitisch
moment mal
wagners heldenrollen vom fliegenden
holländer bis zu am vortag im parsifal
alles sind eindeutig darstellungen des
wandernden juden wagner selbst
bezeichnete den fliegenden holländer als
ahs wer des ozeans erinnern sie sich an
wotan nach der walküre
er wird zum wanderer warten das
grundproblem ist dasjenige des ewig
wandernden lupe er zieht den er verdammt
in alle ewigkeit
er möchte sterben kann es nicht da sind
wir wieder beim stephen king thema die
und wurden deshalb ist wagner für mich
ein wunderbares aber trauriges beispiel
wie jenen der als mensch ein schwein ist
als authentischer künstler ein werk
schaffen kann das etwas ganz anderes
ausdrückt überhaupt nicht alt aber
vielleicht wenn man so ein bisschen
weiter noch jetzt blickt es ruhiger
angehen zu lassen kann man sich jetzt
aber haupt vorstellen nein das einzige
was ich sagen kann ist ich schreibe
diese kurzen politischen bücher heraus
eine art bürgerpflicht heraus meist
dabei nicht ganz voll
ich habe das gefühl über etwas zu
schreiben das ich nicht wirklich kenne
andere müssten darüber sprechen meine
wahre liebe geht dicken wälzern über
hegel und so weiter das war auch so mit
meinem lieblingsbuch weniger als nichts
es zählt über 1000 seiten
das ist worauf ich jetzt lust habe das
einzige woran ich merke dass ich alt
werde entweder schreibe ich mein haupt
verletzt
ich bin ein klassischer moral ist ob sie
es glauben oder nicht
dadurch wurde ich in einem seltsamen
konflikt hineingezogen
erinnern sie sich als roman polanski er
verhaftet wurde mein gott
ihr habt es getan in der schweiz einige
leute sind mit der bitte an mich gelernt
sollte dagegen protestieren
okay es war unsinnig ihn zu verhaften
aber auf eine art hatte etwas äußerst
schmutziges getan
somit hat er nicht automatisch meine
sympathie große künstler wir sollten ihm
vergeben
was sind sie denn verpflichtet wenn sie
solche bücher schreiben müssen
es ist eine art allgemeine bürger
verpflichtungen dabei abgesehen davon
bin ich ein moralist im sinne von mein
gott das klingt jetzt fast
protestantisch theologisch und max wey
vision sinn
ich denke das klingt jetzt schrecklich
jeder von uns hat eine innere berufe die
man spüren und dem man folgen muss wenn
sie das nicht schaffen ist ihr leben
verloren
das ist eine sehr traditionelle moral
nicht mehr
ja ich tue was ich mag
in den ersten jahren am gymnasium gab es
eine kurze zeit da wollte ich
filmregisseur werden
dann sah ich all der filmklassiker und
akzeptierte dass sich dafür zu blöd bin
aber mit 17 wusste ich dann philosophie
ich bin sehr glücklich damit trotz aller
traumata in meinem privatleben ich tue
was ich tun will und ich bin damit nicht
glücklich glück ist für idioten
ich finde es zutiefst befriedigend das
zu tun was will man mehr auf dieser
dreckigen erde haben sie sich irgendwann
im laufe ihres lebens irgendwo
theoretisch gesehen geehrt gibt es
positionen von denen die sagen die waren
falsch die werde ich nicht mehr
vertreten
natürlich verändere ich meine position
auf sanfte weise aber im grunde ist es
äußerst merkwürdig weil sich 23 24 jahre
alt war entdeckte ich zusammen mit
einigen freunden dieser achse
noch nicht rom berlin sondern hegel
lacan der hier sind immer noch dort und
sehr zufrieden damit
dabei sind wir nicht festgefahren
wir ändern unsere standpunkte aber die
grundlegenden koordinaten unserer arbeit
sind seit 30 jahren die gleichen aber
trotzdem moment trotzdem gibt es in
diesem ganzen radikale änderungen link
wie bei einem anderen meiner lieblings
philosophen shelley ja ja dasselbe aber
die veränderungen vom frühen schellin
die identitäts philosophie bis zum
späten schelling mit dem weltalter das
ist ein ungeheurer wandel wie ein
erdbeben
das gleiche gilt für das heißt nicht
dass wir ständig die gleichen ideen
wiederholen
wir kämpfen immer mit dem gleichen grund
problem finden aber stets andere
antworten
sie haben einmal gesagt sie mögen
eigentlich nicht so sehr weil ich mich
vor interviews fürchte wissen sie ich
sage es mal so das mag sie überraschen
wissen sie weshalb ich so viel spreche
ich habe einen wie sagt man
minderwertigkeitskomplex ich habe angst
wenn ich eine sekunde lang nichts sage
verschaffe ich ihnen einen freiraum in
dem sie verstehen was ich wirklich sagen
und sie könnten merken dass es bullshit
ist um zu verhindern dass sie distanz
gewinnen aus ich also dauernd reden um
sie abzulenken und ihnen keine
gelegenheit zu geben einen schritt
zurückzutreten und zu sagen oh mein gott
was für ein bullshit
ich habe großes misstrauen mir gegenüber
nein nein es ist los es ist nicht so
dass ich glaube ich seine größte es ist
die angst dass sie mich durchschaut
ideologiekritik geht es jetzt in der
sternstunde kunst gleich weiter wir
zeigen ihnen eine bbc dokumentation über
das musik
daft punk die roboter ähnlichen musiker
erobern die welt ohne ihr gesicht zu
enthüllen und hebel mit ihrer kunst alle
gängigen mechanismen des musikbusiness
aus ich stelle schon wie philosophie
blick nächste woche nach großbritannien
nach der abstimmung um den dreck sieht
diskutiert mein kollege stephan
klapproth mit harmonien und ulrike gero
wie es auf der insel weiter geht um was
der entscheid für europa bedeutet ich
danke ihnen fürs interesse und wünschen
ihnen einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]